Speaker 1: Let's go next to oh, I don't know.
We've been we've been so in the US today.
Let's try Peter from Dublin.
Peter, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, how are you doing?
I'm doing well.
Long-Time listener, First-Time Caller American
is a bit of a guilty pleasure for me, I suppose.
While I used to be a fan of the classic fantasy
series The West Wing many years ago.
Yes, I just wanted to say that I really, really
enjoy listening to your balanced, well-informed
commentary.
Thank you all.
So thanks for that.
As a general comment, I do have one more specific
thing.
So it is related to the commentary piece.
So it's about Margaritaville.
Taylor Green, my favorite character, I'm sure.
So I'm just wondering, don't you think that
mainstream media are making the same mistake
in relation to her, what they did with Trump?
And what I mean is they give her a lot of
free screen time every time she says something
completely absurd or, you know, outrageous.
And we know she does that a lot.
So we'll just not promote the dangerous character
of an order like it seems to be already happening.
If you look at her fundraising figures and,
you know, the mainstream media are none the
wiser after how they promoted Trump in 2016.
And like, she knows very well how trolling
works.
So I wouldn't be just safer to just, you know,
to not feed the troll and ignore her stupid
comments instead of going, yeah, it's another
stupid thing.
I know she's a member of Congress.
Right.
But what do you think about that?
Speaker 1: Here's the problem.
This comes up all the time.
This this is an ongoing question.
Here's the problem.
If serious media and left wing media ignores
her.
And right wing media continues to hold her
up as a hero.
That is the only message that gets out.
Now, you might say, well, right wing media
only talks about her because she's so triggering
to normal media and left wing media.
I don't think that that's the case.
I think that this is someone who, because
of her personality and because of her affiliation
with Trump, is popular in right wing media.
Now, is there some degree to which you're
right that as she gets more media coverage,
right wing media becomes even more sycophantic
about her and gives her more coverage?
Yeah, probably.
But they would be covering her anyway.
And the problem with not addressing that,
there is someone in the House of Representatives
who thinks masks are like the Holocaust.
And I think she was one of the people with
Lauren Bobert who wants guns on the House
floor and all this different stuff.
The problem is that if reporters ignore it
and left wing media ignores it, the ideas
don't go away.
It is seen increasingly by the right as legitimate
to have someone like this in the House of
Representatives.
And I fear that it just grows.
So I've just not seen any evidence that ignoring
it, quote, ignoring it is really a solution
to anything.
Speaker 4: OK, do you think that she she's
doing that on purpose, like, is it the marketing
tactics?
Because it does remind me very much of the
marketing tactics of the airline Ryanair that's
in the news recently because of what's happened
in Belarus.
So, yeah, their CEO many years ago, like every
now and then, he would say something completely
ridiculous publicly like that.
He will only introduce, you know, one pilot
to save money or offer something, tickets
or something, something completely impossible
with the plane and all the newspapers all
the time or radio shows would pick it up and
start discussing as if it was a serious thing.
And every time they would say, oh, low cost
airline Low-Cost Airlines, so that, you know,
got embedded in people's brains.
So is it possible that she's doing that on
purpose so that, you know, if, as you said,
you know, some of the more right wing leaning
will watch, you know, mainstream media, they
will see her and it will be just, oh, look
at her owning those flip darts again.
You know, like is this do you think she's
smart like this or is it just, you know, accidental
that?
Speaker 1: I think that it's a combination.
I think to some degree she knows that there
are types of things that she can say that
will get her attention.
A lot of it isn't good attention.
I don't think she's so brilliant at it, though,
that she's doing it in a way that really benefits
her.
I think there's a good chance she gets absolutely
crushed in in November of twenty twenty two
and then that's it for her.
So I think that it works in getting her attention
right now.
Whether it will really achieve or serve some
bigger purpose, I don't know.
I think it actually could be disastrous for
her.
Speaker 4: David, thank you very much.
Much appreciated.
Speaker 1: All right, Shalin Island, very
much appreciated.
Thank you so much.